folks, I'm back for
another, let's say, hour and a half.
Oops.
[Music]
Um, I think we're just going to see if
what we can do about offline I mean off
policy right now and uh then we
will integrate everything tomorrow.
And hopefully we will go from there. We
will
this. Oh yeah, I see it. Okay, that's
good. That's a good result so
far. That's like very nice.
very slightly
above roughly same stability, maybe a
little more. I don't know. We're happy
with that. We're definitely happy to see
that. Okay.
Um, hey bet, welcome.
Yeah, the shape just doesn't blend at
all, does
it? No, no, it's the stupid um blueprint
stuff.
go back to this for a second.
So offline data really doesn't all
policy data isn't the thing that's
screwing us. It's the prioritization of
that data
somehow. That's really weird.
Wait, what the
hell?
Wait, this samples with importance. Oh,
but importance is advantages. So, this
is
[Music]
fine. This thing, this random sample is
the thing that messes with
it. Hang
on. Yeah, there's like really no
difference with the prioritization for
this.
So, you're not expecting it to do
better. You just want it to not do
worse.
Maybe the importance ratio is not
getting used
correctly. We'll have to
see. Yeah. So, this is the worst curve.
You can see
it. Yeah, it's following this path.
Okay.
So, maybe there's something in the
experience ratio for
us for us to think about, right?
Oh, this thing doesn't get updated at
all, does
bit. I mean, advantage takes into
account both of these things already.
As long as you're using the correct
updated ratio, which we are,
ratio is like technically stale,
but you can't do anything about that
without doing another forward pass,
right?
I mean, you would think that the really
high advantage trajectories would be
long. Maybe that's it, right? cuz like
isn't top K way
worse? Yeah, this is the top K one was
way down here, right?
So if you keep the same samples around
for a long time,
um they get more and more off policy.
Maybe
is there a reason to like keep it
anyways.
Is there a reason to keep this anyways
versus just like running more epochs?
Maybe this corrects so that we can use
it more than
Did you accidentally paste what you were
working onto the into the stream chat
there, Morgan?
Okay, this is what we do. Go to none.
Here's our benchmark.
All right, enough random code snippets
in the chat.
using I know it's Python, but you can
use Java.
JavaScript to do
things. Not an AI. You
can't. I'm not running
freaking JavaScript, PyTorch
models. I like my current stack of
Python and
C. Lot of C, little Python.
even. So now we see how this does with a
bunch of extra updates.
This might be too easy to use as a
proper benchmark, but we'll see.
Okay. So, I mean this is expected. More
update epochs makes it train slower but
more sample efficient. Yeah.
This is like an interesting spike
here. Oh, you know what this probably
is? This is probably when it wins the
first stage of the game, right? Cuz this
is half the score. It's probably really
annoying to get it to get that last
is.
Okay, so here's our graph.
um it's more sample efficient obviously.
Now the question is going to be what
happens when we compare this to the new
advantage function cuz this is
technically like slightly off policy
data now right
like it got all this extra
data, but it really didn't learn that
much faster with PO, right?
Okay. So, this is our baseline with
PO. Now we do puffer advantage.
maybe. Yeah. But we're not seeing like a
massive increase in sample efficiency or
anything.
Yeah, it looks like this is probably
just going to be like a relatively minor
but permanent bump, right? Where it's
like slightly
better. I don't know. I like conceivably
it could just do it in half the time,
right?
know. I mean, so far here we're doing
like it's kind of consistent, right? We
just do slightly slightly
think. Well, I mean, the thing is
like the fact that this isn't a massive
difference tells me like I don't think
that this is a massive sample efficiency
gain. It's like a nice little boost. I
think it'll make all your curves a
little bit
Um, well, I mean, if you want power to
find much of a difference, this is the
graph, right? This is going to be the
neural MMO one.
I mean, I was testing something very
specific here, right? I was testing the
ability of this algorithm to make uh to
reuse data versus the other
one. Actually, you know what? I have a
better way of testing it. You're right.
this. In the meantime, I'll look at B
trace a little
bit. We should probably graph some of
these as well or like log
Yeah. Okay. So, this was the concern
here, right? You go 12 update epochs and
it starts doing worse, slightly worse,
which is the same as
um GA.
So, I don't think that this does it for
off policy correction too
well. It's a nice little
I wouldn't have screwed up the off
policy sampling ability, right? with
um and we can always try this versus B
trace.
Yeah. So, this thing sucks.
Okay. Now, next we just
do we make sure that I didn't mess up
something here.
Like it is technically
possible. I'm
bad. It is technically possible that
vrace is the sample efficiency one.
I doubt it. I highly doubt it.
Like 15% that this does it. Maybe less.
That's being
I want to read a few more off policy
correction things.
Welcome YouTube
folks. We've got the new algorithm
running. It's like just a little bit
better than generalized advantage
estimation, which is what we
expected. Yeah, Vrace on its own doesn't
do anything.
better. It's really weird how bad V
trace is just on its own, isn't
it? Oh, well, you do have to tune it to
be
fair. Hang on. Maybe this wasn't fair.
Maybe I should have tuned it.
Okay, this thing is
ridiculously
inefficient. This is like laughably
hilariously
stupid. Like the things you'll do for
sample efficiency. Holy hell.
Watkins. Agent 57 uses
retrace to compute return estimates from
all policy data. It tends to cut traces
too aggressively when using epsilon
greedy policies, thus slowing down
propagation of information.
alternative return estimator which we
derive from Q of
We propose to use a softer trace cutting
mechanism by adding a fixed tolerance
parameter and taking the expectation of
trace coefficients under pi. So what is
this? Well, this is
like this is like uh V trace right here,
right?
What the hell is this soft Watkins
thing? They have an ablation on
this. Surely they do ablations,
right? Soft Watkins.
is. What is this operator? So they
take is this
one? The heck is this?
Oh, indicator. Yeah.
One. Okay. So, what they doing here is
this is like
um so this lambda
I is the importance ratio clamped port
importance ratio in our
thing. And
here they define a max. They define a
change in
Q. So I think if the Q function changes
too
much they just drop them I
guess. So instead of it being a ratio
it's like a hard clip.
So, it's actually kind of more similar
to this for what we would do because we
don't have the you.
Oh, so this is they do it whenever the
action changes I
guess.
H Oh, so whenever it count Oh, okay. I
see. So whenever the optimal action
changes or
Yeah. The thing is our policies are
stochastic. So
like it doesn't quite work the same. Oh
also uh this experiment failed horribly.
So I not as badly as before, but like
yeah, V trace alone is not
amazing. Okay, so now we know why our
off policy stuff isn't doing great. It's
cuz these things just aren't great with
off policy data.
Yeah. So their stuff is
like this thing
is where is
it? Yeah. So this thing is
um very much dependent on having a Q
function
because they essentially they prevent
data from going off policy.
The trust region masks out the loss at
any time step which both of the
following conditions
sign of the
difference. Well, what's the G is the
return estimate.
isn't there a caution parame that's like
kind of similar to this
Okay. So, they do have a policy
distillation component.
Yeah. So, this totally breaks it,
right? This caution thing totally breaks
it. We don't want
that,
right? We'll double check.
Are there any
other these
Yeah. Okay. So, this is this
recovers like original per here,
right? What? This one didn't seem to be
that great.
I didn't think this Mars thing did
anything either, right?
great. Oh, you dummy. You've been
putting them on the wrong one. All
right, let's try this
correctly. Stop looking at noise.
I must have applied caution correctly,
right? Cuz that was like a a big delta.
So yeah, that's not great. Let me make
sure we're recovering original perf
here. Something I something like making
me uncomfortable with
this. Make sure we recover perf.
Okay, we're not recovering original PF.
Oh, wait. We are recovering original
Perf. These were the high sample ones.
Okay. Yeah. No, we're good. We're good
cuz these were the
uh Yeah, these were
the Yeah, we're we're perfectly good
here.
I got to be careful at this hour. I
start making dumb
mistakes. Did I I think I did apply
caution correctly here to this though,
right?
that. It's 827.
Um, look at PPG again.
right? Where's the algorithm pseudo
code? I'm trying to think if we can like
hack
this. I think we can hack this a little
bit. So, what I'm thinking here,
right, is we
optimize we optimize the
policy and the value function jointly
for an
epoch. And then we can optionally add
additional value function epochs.
value. Okay, I think we try
it. What happened with this
one? Yeah. Okay, I got it right the
first time. This is way worse.
Let me go grab those other previous
graphs as
Yeah, we've got our baselines. This was
like data reuse.
How do we do
this?
KL, we have this up here.
but I think it's just like one ratio
over the other.
We don't want to pull it to the
[Music]
um We don't want to pull it back to the
original policy though.
Yo, Spencer, how's it
going? We made some really solid
algorithm progress today.
We came up with a small but seemingly
very stable general purpose improvement
to advantage estimation.
Oh, I see how this works. Yeah, that's
really
obnoxious. Could be able to start doing
full-time RL going for it. Awesome.
Yeah, let's catch up over the weekend. I
might have some cool uh I might have
some cool stuff for you.
Let me actually go send one message
right now.
though. I know what I can
do. I know what they must do.
amazing. Let me just try to get
something going real quick, right?
something real quick like.
do this
[ __ ] Come
on. What we're going to try to do
here, the thing is it's a little bit of
a
hack. Do I want to do this, man? I think
I'm going to end up unlearning the
freaking policy.
How the hell do you do this? There's
like no good way to
First, we make sure that it doesn't
change
anything. How's your Vim scroll so
smooth?
This What do you mean this?
Like this is just default neo. my
guy with um the one trick is you always
increase your key repeat speed on your
OS.
It's like one of the first things I
noticed is default key ree default key
repeat speed is like
awful. Okay, so I somehow broke
something. I
guess this doesn't
Right. Bim cursor looks
geriatric. I I have a total of two
plugins in this. I've got SEMI because
Python syntax highlighting sucks. And
then I've got
um uh Super Maven for like I don't know
typing speed
boost. So what happened to the epoch
here?
Okay. Is this thing
matching it? So this should match
because
um it should never hit this cloning loss
here. Okay, perfect match. And now it'll
hit the cloning
loss. And we'll see if that does
anything.
Oh,
good. How would you like to see a
reproduction of scaling scaling laws
paper? Which
one? So, the one I know that's like
there's single agent RL scaling laws.
This one's pretty good.
Um, this is Where's the Schulman
one? Yeah, this is the Schulman one. And
then there's the scaling scaling laws
for board
paper. So, it depends which one you
mean.
He was one of he uh he founded one of
the biggest RL Discords back when it was
active. Uh was one of the first people
to go to anthropic. told me they were
like terrified of all of my neural MMO
things because oh no, it's like
dangerous AI and that they were going to
be like the role model for how to do
safe AI research and now they're doing
completely closed source AI resource and
are you know defense contractors as well
which I'm generally fine with but uh not
exactly at all what they said. So, I
don't know. I generally think that the
anth like especially early anthropic
folks are just completely
batshit. Google has a 10% stake. I
forgot about
that. Is that even a
thing? I don't
know. But yeah, I generally like the
early anthropic people are batshit. Some
of them now are probably just like,
yeah, it's a big it's a big AI lab like
the rest of them. But the early like
original split was complete
batshit. Very good paper though. One of
my favorite papers actually. It's like
one of the best done RL papers I've
seen.
faster?
Huh? Interesting.
early anthropic or all. Yeah, like I
said, that
That's immediately better,
right? Not
much is better though.
Yeah, there's not really like a cute
hack way
to do this.
So what I was trying to do is I was
trying to find like a like a hack way to
do something approximately ppg phasic
policy gradients but without the fixed
cost
overhead. Um it doesn't seem like there
is a good way to do that.
There's not really a way we can get
additional value function training in,
right?
could. Okay, one last thing I'm going to
try really quick.
One last thing I just want to try really
quick.
So this is like really low clipping
coefficient and then extra epoch.
anything? Doesn't seem like this does
anything.
Value function coefficients already
quite big.
Okay, so none of these attacks like
really do anything.
you'd have to do full full basic policy
gradient and
um I don't really like that because you
have to go through the whole data set
again just for the privilege of then
being able to do even more
work. I mean I guess it's hang
on. Okay, I actually maybe it's not bad
come to think of it because
times it 9:07. Okay. You know,
maybe maybe it's actually not that
bad. Um, and the reason I'm thinking
that
is you only have to do the extra forward
pass if you get through the whole data
set, right?
or if you get through your if you're
going to do multiple epochs. So, it
should be purely a method of scaling
up. Okay, we'll mess with this tomorrow.
I think that there is actually a world
in which this works. So, I'll explain
the idea briefly. So, here's the thing
with phasic policy gradients, right?
This is the algorithm. Um, this is
normally what you would do with
PO. Okay, so this is now you have to
double your compute and then you have to
redo the whole forward pass. So that's
like another.5 and then you do a bunch
of extra epochs on both of these. So
what I'm going to do instead is it's
just going to be we do one epoch of this
altogether, which is the exact same cost
as what you would do for PO and then if
you want to do more epochs, then you do
this once and then you do this stuff.
Um and then ideally what that means is
that you maintain exact equivalence with
PO but then you add you essentially just
strictly add an option to train the
value function
more and we'll see if that does
something. Hypothesis here is that it
should do
something. Hey Ryan. Yo Ryan, does this
make
sense? Why does that not work?
You just jointly do one PO EPOC policy
loss and value
No, no, no. What I'm saying here is you
just do you literally do the first epoch
of PO stays PO or the first N epochs of
PO stay PO, right? And then you have the
option to add epochs that just train the
value function and keep the PO output
exactly the same via the KL divergence.
So essentially what I'm trying to do
here, right, is they show here that like
you actually make the policy do worse
after a while and I actually I can
reproduce that result as well. If you
just keep putting more data through it,
you do worse because data gets
increasingly off
policy. But you do better if you train
the value function for longer, right? So
what if I just make this split, right?
Where you can do extra
epochs sort of defeat. How does it
defeat the
purpose? It lets you do PO and then do
extra value training, right?
If you just want you don't you do need
the a step you do need the aux step. You
can't tune up value epochs independently
because you're assuming it's a shared
head. And if you have a shared value
head, then uh you craft the policy if
you don't have a behavioral cloning
loss. But you can't have a behavioral
cloning loss while you're also training
the
Right? So I'm saying here is you just
have this. You don't have a separate
value network. You use the shared mode
that they said works right here. You
train. This phase is just PO. You do
PO for an epoch or two and then you do
this and then this gives you the PI. Uh
this essentially gives you your updated
logic for everything and then your new
updates. Go over
that. Yeah, it is a behavioral cloning
loss bet.
I think this might
work. I think this should work.
um they have like this other version of
it though, don't
they? Hang on. Where's this other
version of it?
They don't have the ablation on why this
matters
though. I guess they also say not to do
the ox phase too often,
right? Isn't that a thing? Like don't do
the auxiliary phase too often.
Yeah. Okay. That actually might be kind
of sketchy.
It doesn't. It just says we think they
interfere as far as I know. Well, the
goal is to decouple value function
training. The Well, the thing is the
other thing this lets you do, right, is
this lets you train the value function
more than the
policy, right?
The main result as I read it here is
that if you train the policy more than
an epoch, it does
worse. Why can't you just do that with
PO? You can't just train the value
head. If you just train the value head,
you corrupt the features if you're not
also training the PO loss. You need to
have a behavioral cloning. Like if
you're not going to train the policy
head like to improve the policy, then
you have to behavioral clone it against
where you started at before you started
training this value function even more.
So the goal is to keep the policy doing
the exact same thing while you keep
training the value function more. Right?
So the policy develops for one epoch and
then you can train the policy uh the
value head of the policy a whole bunch
without destroying the policy logics.
separately. I was suggesting right our
default implementation basically always
does one epoch of po right. So I'm
saying do one epoch of PO and then if
you want to do more epoch so if you want
to like crank up compute then what you
can do is you can uh you can go compute
updated logics through the data set with
the thing that you just trained for an
epoch then behavioral clone versus that
so that the policy doesn't change and
keep training the value
head. Okay, this is also kind of sketchy
here, right?
They say that uh the baseline
PO does shite if uh you use separate
networks.
When this gets to 0.6
six. And what are they claiming this
portion a step if you increase value
epox well yeah the I the plan is you do
npo steps optimal is probably one but
it's like prioritize sampling so who
knows
um and then separately right you can do
value function training followed by or
simultaneous even value function
training and behavioral
this expert trajectories. There's
no Gail is Gail offline or something.
There's no expert
data. Yeah, there's no
demonstrations. How the [ __ ] is there an
imitation library? A whole library for
that [ __ ] It's easy.
Suppose supposed to be taking a
break theory craft ppg stuff tomorrow.
Cool. Proton PPG. We could potentially
look
at Why did you say it wasn't great
originally? Did it not reproduce the
paper?
use cleaner else
version. It was just slow I guess,
right? I would imagine it to be
slow combined with PLR which uses value
predictions.
Huh, weird.
So the way I was going to implement it
right base PO is exactly the same zero
change
whatsoever. It purely gives you
additional value function training.
updates. So that's going to mess some
stuff
up. Let me see. There was an aux
frequency ablation.
I this might not be worth doing then if
it's because I you have to do it jointly
for it to be worth
it. Like you'd have to do it
[Music]
jointly. Okay. So this isn't worth it
then, right? Look, this goes back to
6. It shouldn't require that, but I here
I think the whole thing breaks here
because yeah, that basically brings it
back down to
um yeah, if you do it too frequently, it
harms perf. So I was going to do it
jointly. So that's just not going to
work, right?
Did they benchmark this versus just
doubling the network
right? You know, I'm kind of starting to
wonder here, Ryan.
Like, they use two separate
networks, but they say it still works
with this
Where is it? It still works with
um single net.
Well, it actually doesn't make any damn
sense that this works, right? Because
like think about it. Okay, so like they
just have the value function head. The
point is that like the value function
learns useful features that you then
distill into the main network,
right? But there's nothing to distill
because the value head functions just
like a small head.
So there's nothing to distill and
somehow they're still getting
PF. Well, I guess that would mean if
there's nothing to distill, I guess it's
the fact then that they are doing
additional full gradient value training,
right? So, actually, no. This still does
make sense.
[ __ ] I think this will be worth playing
with a little bit
tomorrow. If I weren't exhausted now, I
could probably just do it in an hour. I
think I'll just do it in the
morning. We'll see. If it's not
promising, I won't stick with it very
long.
But this was basically like one of the
methods I wanted to play with
um for increased sample
efficiency. Yeah, I have looked at it a
little
bit. I mean if you read it this way,
right, this is like 2 to 3x sample
efficiency that they are claiming here,
right? This is like doubled sample
efficiency.
3x. Actually, Ryan, here's another
thing, right?
So look at
this. If you do detach the value head,
right? If you detach the value head
here, then wait, what's this B? Oh,
that's just entropy. So if you attach
the value head here, then you can do
this at the same
time, right? Because this doesn't
interfere with this. So you you can do
this at the same time. So this is just
PO with detached value
head. And then every so often you run
this
So you just do this is the joint first
step first
epoch and then you run additional of
these and then every so often you do
this do them together unless well yeah
but the thing is you can always do let's
say you're going to usually do one epoch
of PO you also get one epoch of value
function training basically for
free cuz you batch it,
right? And then this is like a pure
extension,
right? It's just like a pure extension
of
this. You know, one thing I want to try
just real quick before
I What if we just
do and make sure that this is our
baseline. And
then what if you just detach the value
head? What
happens?
Ignore the stop. It still works.
Yeah, it's very close without it
though. Like let's see what happens if I
do. I think that's the same initial
curve,
right? Yeah, this is fine. This the same
initial curve. What happens if I just do
this? Like just literally detach the
value head there.
This is baseline, by the way. These are
like more
epochs. It does
better. Look at that.
It literally does [ __ ] better if you
detach the value
head. I think that's like enough of a a
cue that it's worth looking into, right?
Oh, you know one other thing we can do
real quick that would make it really
that would be really
easy. Hang on. We're going to try
something really really
quick. So this is true or so this is
just PO, right?
Well, apparently something wrong because
uh that shouldn't have
failed. Hang
on. Hang on.
I screw
I wanted to see with detached value
head if you can now just train it
more. You should definitely be able to
just train it more something's wrong.
runs. No, I want to just it's just going
to train the the uh value head more. How
do I I if I zero this loss, it doesn't
do anything, right?
Yeah, this can't do
anything. Running rate
tracking. That could be a thing. It's Mu
on probably maybe similar
annoying. I mean, that doesn't explain
it failing this hard,
Oh, you're a dummy is why I detached the
wrong [ __ ]
I don't
know. Let's see if this is could have
been noise. Let's see if this actually
is like significantly
better. That's still the wrong one. What
the [ __ ] is wrong with me?
This is the one that we're pulling,
right?
Well, maybe this one just doesn't work
at all.
Ah yeah, here's the issue. If you detach
the value head, the network just trains
like [ __ ]
works. That's kind of
crazy. Wait, is that actually
true? That's kind of crazy, right? Like
look, you detach this
here. Can you just
detach? Can you detach this one?
work.
Uh yeah, dude, you can
detach you can detach the policy head
but not the value head.
crazy though? Interestingly, I think I
detached both and that was the best of
all of
them. Let me see for sure.
What's
training? Good
question. Maybe that was a bug. We'll
see. That'd be pretty funny, wouldn't
it? All right. So, you can detach one or
the other.
Uh, and then if we detach
both. Oh, you know why? It was because
this doesn't get called
anyways. This is the for this was called
during eval time. So that's why it
worked and then the improvement was just
noise.
Okay. Yeah, this is not like this will
fail. I'm
sure this will fail.
But still that's interesting, right?
That you can detach the value head but
not
the Yeah. And then you get a failure
because there's no
gradient.
Yeah.
Uh yes.
But I mean that wouldn't really lend
itself to any major conclusion, right?
That just tells you that you need to
learn the both, which is like, yeah,
duh. You need to learn them
Do any of these things have as much
effect as just doing
this? You got to admit it's pretty cool
how fast we can run these,
right? These are 80 mil experiments.
You'd be waiting an hour a piece for
these normally.
right?
[Music]
Um, there's something there. There's
something
here. Start testing dumb ideas on Puffer
Breakout. Well, the thing is it's not
just Puffer Breakout. You can do it with
Pong and that'll run in 20 seconds. And
you can do it in Snake and that'll run
in a minute.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out what the
hell it is the thing that they're on
like they're up to is with
that here. Let's see what happens just
by making the network a little
bigger. Just like magnitude of effect
kind of a thing.
That's
worse.
Lol. Thanks, Orl. Okay. Actually, I
understand why it is that that happens
now, though. That's going to be gone
pretty
soon. That will do better in the
Is there anything to
basic in that
case? It's weird cuz like the ppg they
say the PO baseline with separate models
does
[ __ ] but then like isn't there that
annoying Google like large scale
Didn't these guys find that shared was
way worse for their [ __ ]
Do you think this is stupid capacity
issue?
This stupid shared network thing like
versus separates always bothered me.
I don't
know. The authors of this paper [ __ ]
my stuff at
Google. Do you think they're paper
[ __ ] That'd be
fun because they come up with a lot of
things that don't really hold across the
whole rest of RL
since why I couldn't publish for a year.
Dip
shots. Yeah. The funny thing about this
is these 4,000 choice configurations on
like puffer tasks. This would be like,
you know, a
box. Okay. Well, I think I should go to
bed actually to be fair. Um, and I just
want to do RL [ __ ] 24/7 now until
it's solved. It's like I got the RL bug.
It's got to be
implementation used for Google's
RHF was based on the implementation from
that paper and it had a bug that made it
really bad for a year.
Oh, they are [ __ ]
huh? All
right. They get really weird results
that don't really match anything in the
rest of RL, right? It is also shitty
control stuff,
though. No one used PPO because of
that. They didn't because of one shitty
Oh, man.
What do you say we like who's going to
win, right? The [ __ ] multi-trillion
dollar
company or me with one puffer
[Music]
fish. All right, apparently we have 11
people watching at this hour. Um, so
here's the deal, folks. I got to get
sleep,
but I will be back first thing in the
morning. All my stuff's open source here
at puffer.ai. AI. We made a pretty nice
breakthrough today with the new
advantage algorithm. Uh if you want to
help us out for free, literally for
free. Takes 2 seconds. Just start the
repo. We're almost at 2,000. It'll be
great. Um other than that, you can join
the Discord to get involved with
development. You do not need an RL
background to get involved. Some of our
best contributors, actually all of our
best contributors now, uh, had zero RL
background coming in. Programming
background helps, but a lot of this
stuff's actually pretty nice and easy to
pick up, but there's a lot of like cool
self-contained dev you can do. It's a
lot like low-level gamedev, except do
train superhuman AIs on it. So, join
there if you want to get involved with
that. Uh there's also a blog post on how
to get started and you can follow me on
X for more RL content. But yeah, that's
the vibe around here. We do research
live, some engineering, some science,
some math, and uh yeah, back first thing
in the
morning. I just get a message from
someone like, "Hi,
whatever." Hi, yes, it's me.
Oh, that was separate. Okay, cool. Well,
yeah. See you folks. Thanks for tuning
in. Bye-bye.